depending on how much tension you've
been paying in the architecture industry
spiral staircases are becoming a
phenomenal piece of art
what's going on guys my name is david
thomas and welcome back to the channel
today i'm going to teach you exactly how
to document
this set of spiral stairs we're going to
make it a quick
easy arc 24 video we're not going to go
into every single detail of the spiral
staircase
so hopefully you're going to be able to
follow along learn all the tips and
tricks and then
be able to use this spiral staircase in
any of your projects
i'm also going to split this video up
into two parts we're going to have the
archicad 24
which comes out on the monday and then
we're going to have the twin motion
render which is gonna come out on the
thursday if that's something that
interests you subscribe buttons down
below
like buttons down below smash them both
help it with the youtube algorithm and
let's not waste any more time
let's turn around to these screens okay
so like always we're starting this
with the typical three panel format
you're going to have me down
in the bottom left hand corner you're
going to have the inspirational image
we're looking to create
above me and we're going to have the
program to the right hand side of the
screen
so like always we're going to start with
arcade 24 opening with a brand new
template
i'm in australia so we have the
australian select template available
here
just use whatever template you have
we're going to be using the bare bone
basics for this so clicking ok starting
with
a new project with this tutorial i'm not
going to go and document all the wine
racks in the back i'm not going to show
all the cornices and the ceilings and
all the works i'm just really going to
focus on this spiral staircase
and the traditional and easiest way of
making it so
let's start with a slab tool a generic
slab we're going to click on the
geometric shape
and let's draw let's say a six by
six room so by clicking on that slab
clicking control d
we can move that freely so zooming in by
scrolling on the mouse we have our slab
we have our room
and i'm going to start by creating some
simple walls so selecting the wall tool
and i'm just going to change it to a
generic 90 mil
stud partition changing it there making
sure our walls are on the walls
internal layer remember layers are
extremely important
i'm just going to draw by flipping this
wall by pressing the p command flipping
it around
holding shift going all the way around
and
drawing my room so if you've never used
archicad 24 before
and you've just done all those steps
congratulations it was super super
simple
now if you want to see it in 3d you can
either click up here or right click
show all in 3d and there we go like you
see in the image we have four walls we
have a slab and we're good to keep going
jumping back to our ground floor plan
like i said this is going to be a quick
very rapid fly tutorial just to teach
you guys the absolute basics of spiral
staircases now looking at this
inspirational image we have on the left
hand side or above me if you're watching
this on youtube
it's probably about a meter wide stairs
and then a 500 trunk
tree and another meter wide stairs but
we want to round up to probably about
three meters
so we're going to use our circle arch
tool we're going to select
this secondary image over here we're
going to click once
and we're going to start typing in 3000
by 3000
then we're simply going to click on the
image and drag it
all the way across to center it in the
center of that wall and we're going to
do the
same thing on that side there so now our
circle is perfectly centered to this
room
we're then going to go across and grab
the stair tool holding the space bar
clicking once on and creating our first
set of stairs
so if we go into 3d you'll see that
we've created our first set of beautiful
spiral stairs
with multiple landings along the way you
may or may not like the landings it's
completely up to you how you draw it
with or without landings if you don't
want those landings basically what we
have to do is find the up down position
and click that node there and then we're
going to rearrange the steps
so we can actually drag it back around
that circle and you'll see how
everything changes
so the further we drag it back the less
steps we get the more steps we get
all depends where you position it so if
i bring it back a little bit
click there go back into our 3d you'll
see that it's slightly changed
now if we do that same process again but
do it to a
much more intense level all those stairs
are going to completely change
once again so now we only have one
single landing up here and we have a
beautiful set of stairs
personally i really don't want any
landings in this design so i'm going to
keep going
until i completely diminish all the
landings entirely
and there we go now i basically have
that first very large step that we see
on our image
all the stairs coming up and we have our
landing at the top
now what we want to do is actually just
change the settings of this staircase so
we can create something magical and
beautiful
by clicking control or command depending
on what system you're on with the t
button we open up our settings
and we can go through all the settings
to create something a little bit
different
so in the structure as you'll see this
main image change as we go through it
you can select the flip the flight
you can select the flight structure and
have an i-beam underneath with metal
plates supporting it
you can have it cantilevered through the
concrete or you can have stringers on
either side
which is exactly what's depicted on this
side here you can do the exact same
thing
for the landings as well so we'll do
both of those as a stringer on the side
jumping across to the flights and the
stringers here's where we can actually
manipulate them
and make them work to our advantage so i
believe they're probably about 300
millimeters high and 35 millimeters
thick
you'll see how they automatically change
there to give us
something that we're looking for i'm
then going to move to the landing
itself and do the exact same settings
there
so we change all of those settings now
if we come over to the finish
we can actually change what we see if we
want the tread and the risers only
we can just click on these individual
finishes so
personally i only want the tread on this
design here
to be very similar to our inspirational
image coming across to the tread you can
go through this you can change the
thickness the ball nosing
there's a whole bunch of different
settings that you can initiate if you
want
stair risers stair strips milled
recesses you can really go through this
and add
lots of architectural detail it is a
very very useful
setting on all of these stairs but all
we're really going to do
is just click through and take a look
because there's nothing really for us to
do so now if we click ok we'll see our
stairs completely change right before
our eyes
and what we now have is a beautiful
spiral staircase with a timber
edge beam wrapping all the way around
creating our beautiful structure
so now what i'm going to do is open up
those settings again and i'm going to go
through these
one by one and override everything at
the very end so i'm going to skip
to the end override the beam surface and
override the secondary support
i'm going to just change them all to
white in this instance so paint glossy
white
and repeat the same steps for the
remainder of them so there we go i've
gone through flights landings and tread
change them all to glossy white clicking
okay
we'll see our stairs once again change
that beautiful
white finish that we can render in twin
motion
if we want to so that'll be in the next
tutorial coming this thursday
if you're interested in watching how we
render this beautiful set of spiral
stairs
now to create the right hand rail that
we're looking at we can actually do that
straight away when we're creating the
stairs but i find it
a little bit more challenging a little
bit harder to actually correct it
as you manipulate the stairs and make
them work to how you see best fit
so i actually like to create the
individual railing after
point by point so by default it's on
associative and associative
and what i like to actually do is slowly
move up
this spiral staircase about 300
millimeters at a time
and just clicking after one after the
other i find that this method gives a
much more realistic look
because glass isn't often curved unless
you really have a massive budget for it
so it's usually segmented and it's in a
consistent pattern so it doesn't exactly
have to be 300
i just roughly click where i think 300
is it's quite easy once you get into the
routine of it
i'll work my way up to the top and skip
through this boring part and there we go
i've created my
spiral staircase handrail using the
railing tool all i'm going to do is open
up the settings again command
t to be able to work my way through
these settings here so the writing tool
is a pretty
self-explanatory object to use you have
everything pretty well diagrammatically
pictured
what we're looking for is a single glass
plane without anything in between i'm
not going to go
model the detail at the bottom so what
we're going to start by doing is
clicking on the rails
and removing all of them so just
clicking the minus tab
until all those rails completely
disappear now that our all our rails are
gone i'm gonna come across
the panels i'm gonna introduce a brand
new panel clicking
right there to create our panel and then
introducing it
as a glass panel with no fixings so i'm
going to show
no frame i'm going to show no fixings
it's completely frameless
it's tied in to the bottom of the stair
tread i might actually show a bottom
fixing with a channel underneath so
there's no top fixings it's only a
vertical
channel fixed to the stringer of the
stairs and i'll click ok
just to show you guys how much we've
instantly changed by simply doing that
so now we still have the post in the
middle but we have most of our glass
showing we'll open up those settings
once more by clicking command t clicking
on that central post
removing it going to our post on the
external side
making sure that we have no external
posts showing whatsoever
we go into the node and we change our
pattern continuity
so clicking on continuous pattern
clicking okay we'll see all
of our glass realign and a couple posts
get reintroduced
now there is actually a pretty easy way
to get rid of these inner posts all we
have to do is come back into settings
the last time
click on inner posts here change that to
none
and click ok that's the quickest and
easiest way to get rid of those posts we
don't have to worry about them
and our spiral staircase is pretty much
done
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video
if you did make sure you smash that
subscribe button down below and don't
forget about the like button
the like button helps with the youtube
algorithm it really helps this channel
grow
so i truly appreciate it because we're
trying something new out this week
instead of seeing you next monday i will
see you this thursday